In the name of the Father, and of the Son, and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
Though reading, from the Sinhaxadeon, for October 7th, on which we commemorate, the holy
and great martyrs, Sergius, and Bacchus, on the 7th of the month we celebrate the memory
of the holy and great martyrs, Sergius, and Bacchus.
Sergius and Bacchus lived at the time of the Emperor Maximian, who made them senior officers
in the Skola Gentilium, in spite of their youth, commissioning Sergius as Premi-Cerius,
and Bacchus as Secondi-Cerius.
On a day that the Emperor ordered public sacrifice in honor of the idols, the two young officers
alone refused to participate.
Maximian regarded their insubordination as open mutiny, and had them brought before
his tribunal to explain themselves.
We are obliged to do you loyal service only in your army upon earth, they told him.
Fire and sword will never in the least succeed, in separating us from the one true God whom
we worship, to adore senseless idols, for nothing will make us happier than to suffer
for the faith.
Maximian ordered them to be stripped forth with of their military insignia, and dressed in
women's clothes.
Thus clad they were dragged through the streets with heavy iron collars around their necks
to become the laughing stock of the populace.
As far as Barbalisos on the Euphrates, the headquarters of Antiochus, the governor
of the East, a particularly cruel and merciless man.
The holy young men maintained their composure in the face of the governor's threats and flatteries
alike.
Sergius was kept in solitary confinement while Bacchus was put to the torture.
He was cruelly beaten with sinews of oxen and joyfully gave up his soul to God to join
the army of angels and saints.
The next day Sergius was brought forth.
He was only sorry at still being in this world of vanity while his companion was already
rejoicing in blessedness.
Antiochus labored in vain to make him apostasize, reminding him of the position he once enjoyed
and threatening him with cruel torments.
In the end he put shoes on him with sharp nails inside and made him run in front of his chariot
for nine miles.
As far as the fort of four towers, raised above bodily suffering by the joy of partaking
in the Lord's Passion, the young man ran eagerly chanting the Psalms.
During the night his wounds were healed by an angel so that he appeared before the governor
the next day fresh and ready for new contests.
Antiochus gave orders for his beheading at Rosafa, the next garrison on his way.
In the arrived at the place the saint asked his executioners to give him a few moments
during which he raised up fervent prayers to God for his persecutors.
Then bending his head beneath the sword he departed to join Bacchus in the kingdom of heaven.
The inhabitants of the little town of Surah, where Bacchus had been martyred, wanted to
carry off in secret the body of surges, but the saint stopped them from doing so by starting
a fire.
The Christians of Rosafa ran to the site, drove off the thieves, and put the holy relics
in a safe place.
A church was later built over the tomb of saint surges which became one of the most greatly
venerated sanctuaries of the east.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.